hey everybody thanks for joining us I'm
Katherine manky ward I'm the managing
editor of Reason magazine and I'm just
gonna kind of get us started with a few
questions and then looking forward to
taking questions from the audience so
the death of money
sounds pretty delightfully apocalyptic
can you kind of lay out what that looks
like I know that you've said in other
interviews that you know this book is
actually about what happens after that
and the kind of Reformation but but
first like lay it on us how bad is it
going to be well Thank You Katherine and
I'd like to thank Galileo for the
introduction and the Charles Koch
Institute in Reason magazine for hosting
us tonight so very happy to to be here
that's a great event and a great group
and I always love any occasion to be
back in Washington so the bad news is
that all of the blunders have already
been made we're just waiting for the
catalyst so the the problems are kind of
baked into the pie and the metaphor I
use a lot but I want to make it clear
when I talk metaphorically it's not
really a metaphor metaphor because the
dynamics the mathematics and and the the
complex interactions in various
phenomena are the same so I'll use the
the snowflake in the avalanche which I
talk about in my book you know you're on
a mountainside and you're watching the
snow build up and it builds up and it's
windswept and it's sound overhanging and
it's unstable and anyone with any
experience knows that this is an
avalanche in the making the snow is kind
of I'm not going to stay here it's going
to fall down so a snowflake comes along
and it preserves a few other snowflakes
and that starts a little momentum and
that creates a slide and then a larger
chute and then the whole thing comes
loose and the Avalanche comes down and I
killed some skiers and buries the
village below and that's your disaster
now a couple things number one who do
you blame do you blame the snowflake or
do you blame the unstable snowpack I
would submit that the unstable snowpack
is your problem because if it wasn't one
snowflake it would be another maybe one
the day before one the day after it
doesn't really matter the snowflake
doesn't matter it's going to come what
matters is the fact that you have a very
unstable system and as applied to
finance because that's what we're we're
here to talk about we have
exactly the same situation that the
snowpack if you will is that is the
complex interactions what scientists
called the density function of all the
financial contracts and financial
institutions in the system today in 2008
is not a person in the room who didn't
hear about too-big-to-fail ad nauseam
too big to fail too big to fail well
today in 2014 the five largest banks in
the United States are bigger than they
were in 2008 they own a larger
percentage of the assets of the banking
system their derivatives books books are
much bigger so everything that was too
big to fail in 2008 is bigger and more
dangerous today and you know we all know
that dodd-frank was supposed to
eliminate too big to fail it did not
eliminate too big to fail what it did it
institutionalized too big to fail really
made too big to fail a manageable
statutory policy as opposed to something
that you know you could possibly debate
and so that's the that's the snowpack so
at this point we're just waiting for the
snowflake we're waiting for the catalyst
that will cause this catastrophe to come
tumbling down now one difference between
a natural system such as an avalanche
and a human base system such as the
financial system is that there is the
ability to intervene what imagine an
avalanche is coming down and somehow a
ten-foot steel fence you know popped out
of the mountain and stop the Avalanche
well you could imagine something like
that they don't exist in the real world
but but you could picture something like
that that was the role of the Fed in
other words this cascade that happened
in 2008 was under way Morgan Stanley was
days away from failure after Lehman
after AIG Morgan Stanley would have been
next they were days away Goldman Sachs
would have failed after that then
Citibank then Bank of America who knows
about JP Morgan maybe maybe not but in
all likelihood yes that all the major
banks would have failed that didn't
happen and we know why because the Fed
was the fence it popped up and said now
we're now going to guarantee every bank
deposit in the United States regardless
of size there have been a $250,000 limit
and I say the Fed I'm including the FDIC
in the Treasury and OCC and all the
government agencies combined we're going
to guarantee every bank deposit in the
United States we're going to guarantee
every money market fund in the
States we will not only start printing
money by the trillions but they engaged
in tens of trillions of dollars at the
time undisclosed swap arrangements for
the European Central Bank because the
European banks had dollar liabilities
they owe dollars to the US money market
funds the European Central Bank can
print euros but they can't print dollars
so they couldn't bail out their own
banks because they didn't have dollars
so what they did they printed up a bunch
of euros the Fed printing up a bunch of
dollars they swapped the euros for the
dollars we still have the euros they got
the dollars they use that to bail out
the banks this is by the tens of
trillions so you add up all the
guarantees all the money printing all
the swaps that went into that is far
beyond what you see on the Fed balance
sheet much of that is still in place not
all of it some of it's been on well but
it's all still in place to a great
extent the banks are larger so the whole
thing is worse and more dangerous than
it was we're just waiting for that
snowflake or the catalyst and then one
of the questions I get most frequently
is well what would be you know and then
another variation on the question is hey
Jim I'd like you to call me at 3:30 the
day before the system enclosed because
then I'll I'll sell my stocks and buy
some gold I'll be good to go and I
explain to people it doesn't work that
way you won't know what it is and it
could be a number of things it could be
the failure of a bullion bank to deliver
physical gold on demand it could be the
failure of a financial institution such
as the you know the MF Global that I
think we're all familiar with it could
be a prominent suicide it could be a
natural disaster it could be a lot of
things it doesn't matter it's coming and
the the disaster has already baked into
the pie and it's actually worse the
point I make and I just kind of get back
to the death of money and and where the
book ends up is that the next time it
happens it'll be bigger than the Fed the
Fed did truncate the disaster the last
time I mean they did these other banks
would have failed they didn't so you
have to give the Fed credit for
truncating it although I'd like to say
you know this called the Bernanke is
hero to me he's a guy who set your house
on fire and then shows up with a fire
hose and offers to put it out I don't I
don't give much credit for being a hero
in a disaster that he caused he and
others
but it would be bigger than the Fed
because all the policy that I described
that four trillion dollars approximately
a money-printing it's still there so
what happens the next time there's a
liquidity crisis of the kind we had in
2008 except yonder you know using my
analysis my dynamic systems analysis
it'll be much worse so now you have a
worse it'll create a crisis than we had
in 2008 the Fed did everything I just
described to put out the last one that's
still there what are they going to do
next time
print a trillion twelve trillion there
is some there actually is not a legal
limit but there is some confidence limit
or political limit on what they can do
and that crisis is going to be bigger
than the ability of the central bank's
to snuff it out because they've all
trenched their balance sheets and
there's only one clean balance sheet
left in the world which is the IMF the
Fed is leveraged about eighty to one its
insolvent on a mark-to-market basis and
you don't take my word for that I've had
a recent discussion with an FOMC member
you know can't mention the name Chatham
House Rules but the substance of the
discussion was I said to this individual
you know the feds insolvent I like to
there's a dinner like to be a little
provocative if I can on the
mark-to-market basis I said I know you
don't mark your ballot to market but if
you did they would be insolvent and the
individual said no we're not no one's
done that calculation I said well
actually I've done it and I think others
have done it and the person to murdered
a little bit and said well maybe and
then I just stared at this individual
and and wouldn't wouldn't let the person
off the mat and finally the individual
said well we are but it doesn't matter
central banks don't need capital that
was an exact quote Senator Paul is
already Rand Paul likely presidential
candidate in 2016 has already started to
talk about the insolvency of the Fed if
you think bailing out banks in 2008 was
unpopular where do we have to bail out
the Fed so the point is they're out that
they're at the outer limit of what they
can do in my view the IMF is only
leverage three to one versus eighty to
one for the Fed and so the liquidity is
going to come from the IMF but they
can't print dollars they can't print
sdrs the Special Drawing rights think of
it as well
I mean it is well money they just gave
it a geeky name so people wouldn't know
what it is because well money sounds a
little scary but that's what it is and
that'll be the end of the dollar so
that's that's how it plays out that's
the dynamic what I want to do for
readers is first of all explain really
in scientific space what the problem is
how it's already there we're just
waiting for the snowflake and then look
kind of over the horizon as to what
might come next that was indeed
apocalyptic thank you
so you'd mentioned the IMF and I think
that's a point in the book that a lot of
people have found kind of controversial
or interesting this idea that the
reserve currency could could kind of
land there either after the crisis or
maybe in some sense instead of the
crisis you know what's your take on that
is that is that's something that's sort
of a suboptimal but non terrible outcome
or is that sort of ultimately just
setting us up for the crisis after this
one well it's the only outcome that the
power leads can envision and when I say
power leads you know this is not some
black helicopter conspiracy I mean
they're real people they're finance
ministers Treasury secretary central
bankers leading academics policymakers I
mean there's a real set of real people
who run the international monetary
system and you know I know some number
of them and that that's what I mean by
the policy elites I like to say the IMF
is transparently non transparent and
what I mean by that is they actually
tell you everything they're doing but
the language is so arcane is so
technical that you kind of have to work
at the IMF to understand it I you know
that Garrard an introduction mentioned
that I went to the School of Advanced
International Studies right around the
corner of Massachusetts Avenue what he
didn't say is that that school is
intellectual boot camp for the IMF when
you graduate you kind of three job you
know sort of something in the government
national security maybe the banking
system or the IMF Tim Geithner was one
of our distinguished graduates see the
nice brief career of the IMF so I was
sort of marinated in
early in my career and maintain my
interest in it but there very few people
outside the IMF who actually understand
what they do and the special join right
is is a good example it's one of those
names it's it's a lot like the Federal
Reserve in the following sense why is
the Federal Reserve not called the
central bank of the United States I mean
it is the central bank of the United
States no one disputes that well the
answer is we had central bank's twice
before the American people hated it and
got rid of them and in 1913 the view of
the elites was that while the American
people really don't like central bank so
let's call it something else and see if
we can slide it by and they did so they
called it the Federal Reserve the SDR is
no different Special Drawing right it's
it's world money it's a fiat currency
it's not complicated I've met PhD level
economists who can't tell you what an
SDR is they haven't studied either it's
just a little bit off the run but it's
pretty simple the Fed can print dollars
the european central bank can print
euros the IMF can print SDRs are they
backed by anything
no now you'll hear some assertive
so-called experts say oh you know it's
the basket of currencies it's the dollar
the euro the swiss franc and all that
it's not there is a basket that is used
for purposes of calculating the value of
an SDR the notional value of an SDR for
exchange purposes so you say well how
much does an SDR worth I mean the answer
is it's worth about a dollar fifty five
it fluctuates daily the IMF I'm on their
mailing list they'll send you an email
every day tell you what the what the SDR
is worth that day it's about a dollar
fifty five but the so called basket is
just a bunch of currencies weighted
converted and then added together to
come up with a cross rate but it's a
numeraire it's not backed by those
currencies it's not backed by anything
it's not meant to be and so it's just
fiat money so the question Catherine
really is so if the dollar fails and
when I say fail what does that mean it
means that there's a loss of confidence
in near-instantaneous widespread loss of
confidence in the dollar as a store of
value
it doesn't mean dollars to literally
disappear what it means is that if you
have them you want to get rid of them
you want you want to buy gold you want
to buy silver land
or a friend Warren Buffett who's out
buying railroads or gas oil and gas what
Warren Buffett is a guy who is dumping
paper money as fast as he can one of his
recent big acquisitions was the
Burlington Northern Santa Fe Railroad
and you know your conventional wisdom is
oh well Buffett likes transportation
stocks well no he brought the whole
thing what is a railroad a railroad is
nothing but hard assets it's right away
mining my suggestion to the right away
we're all rolling stock yards which is
signals buildings it's all hard assets
how does the railroad make money
it moves hard assets as Freight coal you
know corn we steal cattle as the case
may be
so a railroad is a hard asset that makes
money moving hard assets Warren
Buffett's next big acquisition was oil
and natural gas resources in Canada and
by the way he's kind of indifferent to
the Keystone pipeline because if you put
a hundred tank cars together you got a
pipeline on wheels and he'll move his
own oil and his own railroad to his own
refineries down the line so he's a guy
who's dumping paper money as fast as he
can getting into hard assets and you go
back to the Weimar Republic
hyperinflation in 1922 23 it's an
episode people are generally familiar
with and we all know who the losers were
you know if you were middle class you
had savings you had retirement you had
insurance you had annuities have any
kind of nominal income you were wiped
out you were destroyed but it wasn't all
losers there were a lot of winners who
were the winners if you were
multinational and you had foreign
currency coming in to Germany if you had
a factory the currency can go to zero a
factory is still a factory it's a
valuable asset some some folks had gold
and the winners went out and brought up
all the losers and consolidated
industrial holdings in Germany and then
they decided that this guy Hitler it
might be a nice pawn for them that
didn't quite work out but but you take
the point so so I watched Buffett with
when it comes to billionaires don't do
what they say watch what they do and
Buffett's getting hard assets as fast as
you can so we'll still have dollars but
in this new world of SDRs the dollar
will be no different than the Turkish
lira or the Mexican peso it'll be a
local currency it'll be walking around
money so if you
to dinner later - now you used ours but
it won't be used for the big things what
do I mean by the big things price of oil
settlement of balance of payments
between countries probably the financial
statements is 100 largest corporations
so in the future when you get your IBM
or General Electric annual report in the
mail or Volkswagen or Siemens or si P
it'll all be denominated in STRs you
know certified by you know our Senor
whoever and at that point there'll be no
turning back the dollar will be just
another another local currency so by the
way in January 2011 the IMF published a
paper it's a 10-year plan to make the
SDR the global reserve currency they
talked about what they need to do that
they need a bond market with reverse
maturities they need dealers rebo's
futures options the plumbing so to speak
of the financial system it's all there
on the website you don't have to make it
up and then two weeks ago on Sunday I
was April 13th if I'm not mistaken but
whatever that Sunday was there was a dry
run for Bretton Woods there was the
annual Nathaniel the semi annual Spring
Meeting and the IMF here in Washington
he had finance ministers central bankers
from around the world and they always
did they do a little g20 on the side a
little bricks on the side and they have
an agenda that runs from Friday Friday
night Saturday
well Sunday they had an unscheduled
meeting they disclosed the existence of
the meeting and a few of the attendees
including the head of the Bank for
International Settlements that's the
central bankers central bank headed the
Swiss National Bank and other leading
economists and figures they didn't
disclose who they were
I'll take a wild guess and guess that
you know people like Barry Eichengreen
and Mohamed el-erian were there I'm not
sure of that but it seems like a good
guess but this was and they explicitly
said in the press release to discuss the
future of the international monetary
system so this was a dry run for new
Bretton Woods this is all in the air
it's all out there I'll be the first
amit it's very little understood but
it's coming your way so we're now going
to make you the dictator of all things
based on your performance here today and
your books
what's the better system what what do we
do instead this sounds bleak sober
things that Catherine your first
question was what give me the
apocalyptic scenario now give you some
good news it's it's not too late to fix
the system it is a question of policy
we're not helpless you know when I
entered currency wars I explicitly said
it's late but it's not too late there
are certain things we can do the death
of money ends on a slightly more
pessimist a pessimistic note which it
kind of says it may be too late to save
the system but it's not too late to save
yourself and your family and your your
personal net worth but just to kind of
walk that back a little bit if you did
want to try to save the system as late
as it is
there are very explosive things you can
do first of all ban most derivatives not
all of them I think the Chicago
exchange-traded futures are they've been
around for 150 years I think they're
relatively safe and sound but but the
you know the the over-the-counter
off-balance-sheet swaps books which are
the biggest part of the problem mainly
because they're understood by
professionals using methods that
misapprehend the statistical properties
of risk they're understood by
professionals as creating net exposure
which is not the right way to think
about it and it's not just a preference
it's you know dynamically you would look
at the gross explosion when AIG failed
nobody was worried about the net
exposure on their books they were
worried about the gross amount that AIG
owed them so you go through this very
kind of quick phase transition or you
know conditional correlation where what
was a net exposure on a sunny day
becomes a gross exposure when you're in
financial distress so you have to think
about the gross exposure nobody in Wall
Street does and if you said for example
we're going to triple the size of the
derivatives books on Wall Street which
they've done since 2008 were going to
triple them how much did the risk go up
well if you stop Jamie Dimon on the
street if he could get close to him and
by the way he knows nothing about risk
he said he's kind of a type-a process
engineer he knows how to merge companies
and create some economies of scale
really doesn't understand risk at all
he would probably say that
pull the system the risk went up very
little because it's you know long-short
long-short long-short you know that all
outcomes down to something that that
number that's fairly small if you ask my
mother my 83 your mother she's quite
bright she's non-economists I said mom I
tripled the system how much did the risk
go up she would probably use intuition
and say he probably tripled the risk you
know a nice linear function mom is wrong
too
the correct answer is if you triple the
size of the system you increase the risk
by a factor of 10 maybe a hundred no is
it's an exponential function and that's
what we're doing so that's the kind of
this kind of risk that's out there so
what should you do about it
well first of all banners derivatives
make them online as fast as they can
break up the big banks when I started
banking JP Morgan's today was 5x it was
the old JP Morgan it was Chase Manhattan
chemical manufacturers Hanover and I
think Wachovia is in there at this point
might be a cut bank bond there might be
a couple other banks but it was five or
six banks all of which were large break
it up get him back to being five or six
backs it doesn't mean they can't fail it
just means if they do fail it doesn't
matter because they're not that big
they're not just systemically important
as JP Morgan the other thing is bring
back glass-steagall you know here's what
happened in the 1920s bankers decided
that it was a good idea to originate
garbage loans package amount micel under
their customers that you could make a
lot of money doing that they stay open
retail offices throughout the country
and they did that and guess what they
all failed we had a market crash
investors lost their money and Congress
had hearings they Pecora Commission and
other hearings in in 1933 in 1934 and
Congress looked at that and said we have
a very simple solution we're going to
say from now on you can do one or two
things you can take deposits and make
commercial loans that's fine or you can
underwrite and sell securities but you
cannot do both because there's an
inherent conflict of interest if you are
taking deposits and using that to create
securities that have garbage in them is
selling them to your customers that's a
temptation
you can't resist that's a conflict
events for seeking be a commercial
banker he can be invested bank
that was the law for sixty five years
until 1999
and then have Phil Gramm and a few
others came along and because for some
ways in the Congress in 1999 I thought
that they were smarter than the Congress
in 1933 I find no empirical evidence for
that in fact there's evidence for the
opposite because they thought well as
the modern age we're a lot smarter we
got computers and all this stuff they
repealed glass-steagall well guess what
within me immediately the bank started
originating garbage assets and selling
it to their customers exactly what
they've done in the 1920s is it any
surprise that by 2007 the entire system
collapsed again exactly has it as it had
1929 so it was you know how many times
they have to get hit in the head with a
two-by-four they wake up and realize
that that conflict of interest is not
going away and you need to you need to
put it back so whether the
glass-steagall was if I'm not mistaken
kind of 15 or 20 pages
I think dodd-frank was 1800 pages and no
I know it's read it but so oh yeah so
put that glass-steagall on we had just
as a quick aside we had a near
catastrophe and near complete global
failure the system in 1998 I know I was
there I was the general counsel of
long-term capital management which was
the entity at the heart of this
particular crisis we were we were on the
phone to the Fed the Treasury
we were hours away from every market in
the world not opening I'm not saying
maybe they opened a week later but they
were they were all not going to open
every market was going to fail until on
Tuesday September 29th but Wall Street
cobbled together four billion and we
stuck it on the balance sheet made an
announcement create a confidence the Fed
cut the discount rate they cut it again
and sure meeting and some house
stability was restored now if you looked
at that and I did look at it I was there
you would draw a set of conclusions you
say you know we really oughta ban
derivatives we really ought not to let
the banks get mixed up in this we really
want to reduce leverage those should
have been your three takeaways from a
near near global collapse instead what
happened in the next four years policy
did the opposite they repealed
glass-steagall so they are the banks
become hedge funds they repeal swaps
regulation in 2000 so that you could do
right swaps on anything
Basel Basel to allowed the banks to
increase leverage and then finally the
SEC did their part by repealing or
amending rule 15c 3-1 which is the net
capital requirement so he could leverage
30 to 1 instead of 15 to 1 it you know a
average bright grad student could have
seen the crisis coming in fact you know
I did others did and then some of them
did because it was a toxic mix the exact
opposite of what he would have
recommended so I would say put the genie
back in the bottle bring back
glass-steagall break up the big banks
ban derivatives reduce leverage and that
way you'll still have you know morons
and you'll still have failures but they
won't take down the world all right
we're going to do a quick lightning
round yes/no questions and a couple of
sentences and answers and then we'll
take questions from the audience
first yes/no question do you consider
yourself a follower of the Austrian
school I'm a complexity theorist and if
Levin Amis were alive today he would be
one too that is a lightning rod answer
my friend I you involved with
singularity University how does that
dovetail with what what you've just
talked about today you get the smallest
people in the world all in one room it's
an amazing phenomena it's you know it's
sort of it's the brain people and the
money people at like a mixer you know so
that's one way to describe it but it
really is an impressive actually that's
one of the things that gives me
confidence I'm very pessimistic about a
lot of things but when you meet some of
these in new idea entrepreneur people
there's a little bit of encouragement
there you've said that an ideal
portfolio should contain 10% fine art
why I find out behaves the way gold
would behave if central bank's didn't
manipulate it which means it performs
very well Johnny Allen does not wake up
in the morning say you know we really
got to crush the art market today
it's it's
it's a good proxy for gold without the
volatility student loans are the new
subprime mortgages question mark I take
away the question mark is one trillion
of them by the way as I discussed it in
my book not only are they the news first
or we're creating a generation of debt
slaves you know the number of 20 really
bright 23 24 year-olds you meet who just
graduated from Ivy League or elite
University they've got $200,000 in debt
no job and they're living in mom and
dad's attic and they can't pay their
student loans by the way there are two
and only two debts that you cannot
discharge a bankruptcy bank bankruptcy
is the all-american system it's like we
all make mistakes people borrow too much
things don't work out as planned you get
to wipe the slate clean in a fair way
and make a fresh start that's that's the
American Way and you do it again you
know so that's for bankers but there are
two things you can't get rid of the
bankruptcy one is taxes well that makes
sense right it'd be too easy to get rid
of your taxes the other one is student
loans so you can't get rid of them if
you can't pay them what happens your
credit rating deteriorates try getting a
job at the very credit rating because
employers are doing background checks
and they use credit ratings as an
additional for them so they won't hire
you try getting an apartment same thing
so now we got our best and our brightest
their debt slaves can't get out from
under can't get a job can't get an
apartment what a great system why are we
doing this because this is a backdoor
off budget way for the Treasury to pump
hundreds of billions of dollars and
supporters of a trillion dollars now
into the system without congressional
appropriation and with two students who
have the highest propensity to spend of
anyone I can think of and where's the
money goes to Union faculty and union
administrators who raised the price so
this is this is a disgrace
you know let's give the students you
know college is expensive what's given a
loan well all the colleges do is raise
the price so the students know further
ahead except they got two more zeros on
their on their on the liability side of
the balance sheet and the Union
unionized universities are taking all
the money in the Treasuries pumping an
ounce this is a backdoor stimulus
program that's another way you can get
off on your student loans
if you take a government-approved job
there all kinds of you know will cap
your interest payments will forgive it
after 10 years but please do what we
tell you
final question can Bitcoin save us all I
will see Bitcoin can save itself the
here's but my two least favorite topics
are Bitcoin and Tesla because the the
people who believe in them are
impervious to any kind of they they're
just they take it too hard and you can't
kind of hard to have a good debate but
on the serious there I'm not anti
Bitcoin I'm Pro technology
I've actually been dragged into enough
of gold versus Bitcoin debates I've had
to study all the Bitcoin papers and the
scientific papers and actually know
fairly well I'm all for it it's cool
it's distributed it's open source it's
robust it's encrypted it's useful it's
cheap it's got a lot of things going for
it so by all means that people want to
transact bitcoins that's fine I don't
own them I don't recommend them to
investors a couple of reasons number one
Bitcoin has not been through a business
cycle as an event in 2009 we've only
been in a growth cycle since then it's
it's an anemic weak pitiful growth cycle
but it hasn't been a down market hasn't
been a technical recession so we don't
know how Bitcoin performs in that
environment and there its enormous ly
volatile I mean that you're the
crossroad between the dollar and the
euro it's actively traded and Milus you
know fractions of a penny they measure a
changes in the front exchange market to
four decimal places of a dollar so
that's how you know if it moves a couple
in one day that's that's volatile
Bitcoin you know go from 300 to 400 to
500 down to 175 back up to 600 it's
funny you know fasten your seat belt but
it's a little too volatile for my taste
but I have nothing against it I wouldn't
ban it I like cool technology
unfortunately we're out of time so I
think we better end there feel free to
come up and mob gym with your questions
afterward and thank you for joining us
you